bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat cet après-midi
dans une salle de conférences vous le
voyez autour de moi complètement déserte
puisque la cession extraordinaire d'été
est bien c'est achevée en fin de matinée
au Sénat avec l'adoption définitive ce
matin du projet de loi sur l'agriculture
cet après-midi nous vous proposons de
voir sur notre organisme qui a eu lieu
hier soir en séance avec l'adoption
définitive d'un autre projet de loi du
gouvernement autour de la réforme
ferroviaire cette fois donc adoption
définitive de ce texte par le Sénat hier
soir
seuls les groupes communistes et UMP ont
voté contre cette réforme du
gouvernement une réforme ferroviaire qui
avait mis je vous le rappelle et bien
une partie du personnel de la SNCF en
grève il y a plusieurs semaines de cela
donc direction l'hémicycle du Sénat pour
voir la fin de cette discussion autour
de la réforme ferroviaire très bonne
séance à tout sur notre tête et très bon
été à tous monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il nous reste à examiner
les conclusions des commissions mixtes
paritaires
sur le projet de loi portant réforme
ferroviaire et la proposition de loi
organique relative à la nomination des
dirigeants de la SNCF je vous propose
donc d'ouvrir la nuit afin de terminer
l'examen de ces textes il y a-t-il des
observations
il n'y a pas d'observation il en est
ainsi décidé
on va laisser monsieur leur rapporteur
s'installer
merci Monsieur le Ministre
l'ordre du jour appelle donc l'examen
des conclusions des commissions mixtes
paritaires chargés d'élaborer en texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi portant
réforme ferroviaire et de la proposition
de loi organique
relative à la nomination des dirigeants
de la SNCF dans la discussion générale
commune la parole est à Monsieur michel
Teston rapportort pour le Sénat des
commissions mixtes paritaires monsieur
le sénateur vous avez la parole
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cher et chers collègues
la commission mixte paritaire réunit le
16 juillet et parvenu à un accord sur
les dispositions restantes en discussion
du projet de loi de réforme ferroviaire
d'une part et de la proposition de loi
organique relative à la nomination des
dirigeants de la SNCF d'autres pas sur
le projet de loi 30 articles restés
tandis que
21 ont été adoptés dans la rédaction du
Sienna les principaux apports de la
commission mixte paritaire sur les
autres articles sont les suivants à
l'article premier bis A
le dispositif des contributions locales
temporaires introduit par le Sénat
l'initiative notre collègue Philippe
Marini a été réservé aux aménagements
extérieurs des gardes d'intérêt régional
et locales en outre leur bénéfice
reviendra exclusivement aux
collectivités territoriales qui ont fait
le choix de les mettre en place par
ailleurs pour éviter que cette ressource
ne devienne permanente la durée
d'imposition maximale a été réduite à 10
ans au lieu de 30 ans à l'article 2 la
CMP a retenu le principe de la
définition par le Parlement des rations
nécessaires à l'application de la règle
de maîtrise de l'endettement de SNCF
réseau elle a en revanche supprimer la
référence à la loi de finances dans la
mesure où les ratios doivent déterminés
dans une perspective plurie annuelle la
commission aussi insistée sur la
nécessité de prendre en compte les
conditions de la concurrence intermodale
un article 4 elle a précisé l'émission
dans le cadre desquelles la RAF consulte
le gouvernement afin d'exclure
expressément de cette procédure les
missions exercées par l'autorité en
matière de règlement des différents et
de sanctions un article 5 bis la
commission mixte paritaire a étendue au
STIF en plus des régions le bénéfice de
l'ouverture des données des services
conventionnés la CMP n'a donc pas remis
en cause les grands équilibres atteints
lors des débats l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat car il était nécessaire sur un
sujet aussi important de voter un texte
équilibré et adapté en effet la réforme
du système ferroviaire est nécessaire et
urgente
elle assure la cohérence du système
ferroviaire tout en ira tout en étant
heureux compatible en outre elle rend
possible la construction d'un cadre
social commun à tous les travailleurs de
la branche ferroviaire quelques mots
pourraient payer ses affirmations
premièrement la réforme est nécessaire
la situation actuelle
issue de la loi de 1997 n'est pas du
tout satisfaisante une partie non
négligeable du réseau à vieilli faute de
moyens suffisants pour le régénérer le
développement du réseau à grande vitesse
jouait à la non reprise de la dette de
la SNCF par l'État se traduit par 37
milliards d'euros de dettes pour RFF le
gestionnaire d'infrastructures la
logique système entre guillemets ne
fonctionne pas bien nulle part au monde
l'infrastructure n'est coupée en deux
comme en France avec d'un côté RFS et de
l'autre la direction des circulations
ferroviaire et SNCF Infra deux filiales
de la SNCF cette césure à créer de la
redondance des surcous et de grandes
difficultés au quotidien pour améliorer
le service rendu aux usagers voyageurs
et chargeurs et aussi pour améliorer la
performance économique afin de
stabiliser l'endettement il a été décidé
de regrouper RFS la DCF et SNCF Infra
dans une structure SNCF réseau qui sera
le gestionnaire unique des
infrastructures et en charge de la
circulation des trains pour autant le
système ferroviaire reposant sur un mode
guidé il faut t'éviter que les questions
d'entretien soient disjointe des
contraintes de l'exploitation d'où
l'idée d'un groupe public industriel
verticalement intégré avec un épic de
tête qui assure le contrôle et le
pilotage stratégique la cohérence
économique l'intégration industrielle et
l'unité sociale du groupe public
cette organisation me paraît adaptée
elle a d'ailleurs été retenu depuis
longtemps par la Deutsche ban ou une
holding de tête chapeau de société l'une
s'occupant des infrastructures et
l'attribution des chiots l'autre est en
exploitant ferroviaire cette
organisation est reconnue unanimement
comme celle qui assure le meilleur
fonctionnement deuxième point de mon
intervention cette réforme est non
seulement nécessaire l'électrocier
urgente la réforme doit intervenir avant
d'option par la Cour européenne par la
par la Commission européenne et le
Parlement européen du quatrième paquet
ferroviaire si la France tardait à
réorganisé son système ferroviaire et ne
le faisait qu'après l'adoption du
quatrième paquet il n'est pas impossible
qu'elle soit obligée de séparer
totalement le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures et l'exploitant
historique cette réforme assure donc la
cohérence du système ferroviaire tout en
étant heureux compatible c'est le
troisième point sur lequel je suis resté
insisté le rattachement du gestionnaire
unifié d'infrastructures SNCF réseau à
l'exploitant historique SNCF mobilité
océan de groupe unifié les pics SNCF ne
devrait pas poser de problème puisque
des dispositions sont prévues pour
assurer l'accès non discriminatoire au
réseau et SNCF réseau sera indépendant
en matière d'allocations des sillons et
de tarification de l'usage des
infrastructures c'est-à-dire pour les
deux fonctions essentielles reconnues
par la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne et la Commission européenne
cette indépendance sera assurée par
ailleurs par les pouvoirs reconnus en la
matière à l'Autorité de régulation des
activités ferroviaires enfin pour tirer
les conséquences négatives de la
libéralisation à la hussarde du fret
intervenu il y a quelques années la
réforme a pour objectif d’éviter le
dumping social en cas d'ouverture à la
concurrence de tous les services
ferroviaires de transport de voyageurs
en permettant la construction d'un cadre
social commun à tous les travailleurs de
la branche ferroviaire ainsi le statut
des cheminots est maintenu un décret
socle définira les règles applicables en
matière de durée du temps de travail
une convention collective du secteur
ferroviaire sur un négocié au sein d'une
commission mixte paritaire représentant
les employeurs et les salariés du
secteur chers et chers collègues voilà
les réseaux pour lesquelles je vous
propose d'adopter ce projet de loi sur
lequel l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
ont travaillé même dans la main avec le
souci de renforcer le service public
ferroviaire je remercie tous les
collègues députés sénateurs qui ont
travaillé sur ce projet de loi et
notamment celles et ceux qui sont
intervenus en commission
séance publique et commission mixte
paritaire j'adresse un grand
remerciement agile Savary rapporte du
proche de Loire à l'Assemblée nationale
qui a fait adopter le texte dans un
contexte marqué par une grève à la SNCF
je savais rien je suis intégré un
certain nombre d'amendements qui ont
amélioré le texte je pense en
particulier aux amendements qui ont
renforcé l'intégration sociale au sein
du groupe public il a en outre accepté
d'échanger régulièrement avec moi durant
la longue période qui a précédé l'examen
du projet de loi par le Parlement ce
travail dans la concertation nous avons
poursuivi activement pendant les
semaines d'examen du texte par le
Parlement je tiens donc à rendre
particulièrement hommage à Gilles Savary
à sa compétence son engagement son sang
du dialogue et son respect des collègues
qui soient députés ou c'est note
me remerciements s'adresse également à
Monsieur le Ministre et assez
collaborateur avec qui les échanges ont
été nombreux et fructueux remerciements
enfin à la responsable de la commission
du développement durable à
l'administratrice et l'administrateur de
la commission qui m'ont beaucoup aidé
dans mon travail ainsi qu'à
l'administrateur de la commission des
finances qui accompagné François Patriat
rapporteur pour avis de cette commission
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à Monsieur Frédéric cuvilliers
secrétaire d'État chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche
merci madame la Présidente sur le
rapporteur d'un messieurs et sénatrice
de sénateurs
avant d'intervenir devant vous avec vous
sur la réforme ferroviaire je
souhaiterais quelques instants évoqués
la tragédie qui vient de frapper notre
pays
cet après-midi je me suis déplacé en
compagnie
du ministre de l'Intérieur Bernard
Cazeneuve pour exprimer la solidarité
l'émotion de la nation tout entière en
dédiée
remercier les secours les forces de
l'ordre mobilisés
suite au drame cet accident
extrêmement douloureux
de ce minibus qui transportait des
enfants
avec un bilan très lourd des jeunes vie
qui sont fauchées
je tiens à exprimer bien sûr aux
familles aux proches exprimer à votre
collègue
monsieur le sénateur maire de Nangis
Michel Billoux toute notre compassion
notre solidarité et l'expression de
notre amitié ce sont des moments
difficiles d'autant que ce voyage était
organisé par la commune qu'il y a là une
responsabilité supplémentaire qui est
vécu subit et les drames qui
sont ainsi ce que nous subissons
n'enclus de portée lorsque en plus il
s'agit de services destiné aux jeunes de
nos communes et
pour leur offrir des vacances pour leur
offrir des distractions des encadrements
des accompagnements
que toutes celles et ceux qui
sont touchés par ce drame un de plus
dans le domaine des transports
reçoivent notre sympathie et notre
solidarité elle est entière l'enquête
judiciaire est en cours engagé et le
bureau enquête accident
là aussi mobilisé permettront de
préciser les circonstances de ce tram
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs nous
arrivons donc ce soir ce matin
au terme de l'examen parlementaire de
notre réforme ferroviaire
je tiens à vous remercier monsieur le
rapporteur
vous remercier très sincèrement du
travail accompli qui a été mené
adresser mes remerciements aussi à
toutes celles et ceux qui se sont
impliqués qui se sont saisis de cette
réforme qui ont contribué l'ont
améliorer dans le respect des
prérogatives du Parlement le
Gouvernement a souhaité que toute la
place soit faite au contribution
parlementaire elles ont été nombreuses
et elles ont amélioré le texte initial
pour donner plus d'ampleur encore à la
réforme ferroviaire vous êtes investis
dans ce grand défi et vous aurez dans
quelques minutes quelques heures le
dernier mot le dernier vote le vote
d'une réforme que nous souhaitons être
une grande réforme non pas une réforme
définitive du réseau ferroviaire du
secteur ferroviaire
mais comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
devant les députés une réforme qui doit
donner un cap nouveau un nouveau cadre
et qui doit être capable de redonner
confiance et espoir en l'avenir du
ferroviaire nous souhaitons que la
représentation nationale puisse ne plus
être écarté des choix du ferroviaire
celle-ci c'est emparée de l'enjeu
ferroviaire elle s'est réappropriée ces
enjeux d'aménagement du territoire de
cohésion sociale de développement
économique et industriel
ça n'est que
légitime et c'est aussi un acte fort de
confiance
et surtout du fait que la nation par ses
représentants devait être assuré la
mission qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû
abandonner ou dont elle n'aurait jamais
dû se départir je vais pas revenir sur
l'ensemble des objectifs de la réforme
encore que un certain nombre de
tressaillants nous permettent de
souligner combien les apports ont été
importants grâce au débat parlementaires
tout d'abord pour renforcer le service
public
avec la création et des fonctions du
haut-commité du ferroviaire celle-ci ont
été grâce à vos débats précisés
associant les parlementaires les régions
les entreprises les organisations
représentant des salariés
ce comité devra structurer les
orientations d'avenir de notre secteur
ferroviaire remettre des enjeux
d'efficacité économique d'équité
territoriales en jeu et notions au
combien importante ici devant la Haute
Assemblée la puissance industrielle
également ce sont des enjeux
stratégiques pour le pays et le Haut
Comité doit se saisir pleinement de ce
que ces enjeux peuvent représenter en
avenir pour le secteur ferroviaire il
doit être le lieu de décision et je le
disais le Parlement a trop longtemps été
tenu à distance il devra se saisir
également des enjeux financiers du
ferroviaire il en refrain juste titre
également vous avez souhaité renforcer
le rôle des régions qui se voient
reconnaître enfin leur implication et
leur place majeurs dans le système
ferroviaire c'était attendu et là encore
cela ouvre les perspectives nouvelles
d'autres réformes qui ne concerne pas
spécifiquement le ferroviaire mais
également le poids et le rôle a été
régions dans la
situation institutionnelle
décentralisée
devront accompagner nous tirons pleine
conséquences de ces évolutions
s'agissant de la création du groupe
public industriel
réunifiant la famille cheminotes et
parlementaires vous-même avaient tenu à
renforcer le caractère intégré du groupe
en affirmant par exemple son caractère
solidaire indissociable de la même façon
vous avez tenu à ce qu'un contrat entre
l'État la future SNCF consolide les
contrats passés par la SNCF mobilité et
la SNCF réseau c'est important cela
donne une structuration supplémentaire à
ce groupe public industriel s'agissant
du Pacte national pour sauver pour
assurer financièrement la pérennité de
notre modèle du service public
ferroviaire national je retiens
particulièrement de dispositions que
vous-même avez souhaité renforcer la
règle de rétablissement des équipes
financiers elle a été retravaillée elle
a été renforcée nous avons eu des débats
de grande qualité je vous en remercie au
cours de ces différents débats vous avez
souhaité que nous finissions avec les
errements qui furent ceux du passé et
qui ont conduit au niveau de dettes que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui et que nous
avons assumer
la prise en compte également de la dette
historique dans les réflexions à
l'avenir et notamment l'état qui
aujourd'hui n'a pas les moyens de
reprendre une partie de cette dette
d'ailleurs cela n'aurait aucun sens que
d'assumer une dette sans même avoir fait
le travail préalable c'est-à-dire remis
le système dans une logique virtuelle
c'est le postulat et après de laisser
l'État dans sa mission à la fois assumer
cette dette historique elle est publique
mais aussi de pouvoir en assurer
l'évolution il a été décidé que la part
de la dette qualifiée de public ferait
l'objet d'un suivi régulier et devant
les parlementaires c'est je crois une
chose indispensable
cela évitera de payer ou de faire payer
un crédit des investissements notamment
à RFF comme cela fut trop longtemps le
cas avec la situation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et les
conséquences notamment sur le réseau et
les difficultés d'entretien sur le
réseau national
tant des priorités ont été autres sans
même s'associer des conditions du
financement c'est désormais une page
tournée avec des règles qui seront
contraignantes légitimement normalement
avec le souci de ne pas laisser peser
sur des générations qui viennent des
choix qui n'auraient pas été
économiquement
étudié et qui ne serait pas
financièrement soutenable s'agissant du
volet social enfin
l'esprit du dialogue l'esprit du
dialogue cette celui qui nous a
inspirait et particulièrement celui qui
m'a inspiré durant des mois de
négociations avec des représentants
syndicaux avec tous les syndicats
certains m'ont même fait reproches
d'avoir co-écrit cette réforme
ce n'est pas pour moi une critique je
pense au contraire que lorsque l'on veut
une réforme d'adhésion il faut associer
largement et notamment les acteurs
les accords qui ont été signés avec ceux
des syndicats qui ont souhaité assumer
des responsabilités de modernisation les
fameux accords de modernisation ce fut
le 13 juin ont donné des avancées
sociales évidentes et je regrette que
toutes les organisations syndicales
n'est pas saisies cette opportunité dans
le Dieu de dialogue supplémentaire et de
pouvoir donner sa chance à cette réforme
et de l'accompagner de ses avancées
sociales elles ont été d'ailleurs au
coeur des discussions parlementaires
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
rapporteur le groupe public disposera
d'instance représentatif du personnel
centralisé des délégués syndicaux
centraux pourtant la négociation
centrale sociale au niveau transversal
une gestion des ressources humaines qui
sera pilotées au niveau de l'Épic de
tête c'est extrêmement important c'était
une revendication avec une gestion des
parcours et de la mobilité au sein même
du groupe public ce qui en fait une
identité de groupe unifié avec le souci
de répondre aux aspirations légitimes de
chacun des salariés en termes de
mobilité de formation
dernier point nous avons assuré que le
cadre de la régulation puisse
s'appliquer nous étions sur le contrôle
du sénateur apocal canelas bien sûr sur
ce point de vue et nous étions attentifs
à le rassurer notamment sur le rôle et
l'indépendance préservée du régulateur
il agira bien sûr au niveau de l'accès
au réseau dans des conditions de
transparence le régulateur devra
maintenant veiller à ce que le système
ne dérive pas non plus en termes
financier
nous sommes
attachés aussi en garantir la dépendance
et notamment par un avis conforme de la
RAF non seulement pour les péages mais
également pour les redevances gare une
étape importante va être franchie avec
l'adoption souhaitée
de ce projet de loi qui pose des
fondements pour assurer l'avenir du
secteur public du service public du
ferroviaire pour le moderniser en
profondeur sur une base qui doit être
solide le travail de la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme va pouvoir commencer dans
les tous prochains jours c'est un
engagement que je souhaite prendre
devant vous tant qu'il est important que
nous puissions par cette réforme
nouvelle associée l'ensemble des acteurs
du ferroviaire bien sûr les salariés de
la SNCF des référent construire de
structurer le nouveau système
j'attends des présidents de la SNCF et
des FF je dois dire le président SNCF
mobilité et des SNCF réseau
de pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
l'enjeu organisationnel de ce nouveau
groupe public dès les prochains jours et
ce en lien avec les salariés
d'ailleurs d'autres événements
dramatiques aussi viennent de se
dérouler il y a quelques jours près d'un
an après la catastrophe de Brétigny et
c'est
cet accident d'Enghien qu'elle est
là encore l'occasion de voir combien il
était important que nous
réorganisions réorientons qui ont les
priorités du ferroviaire drame
douloureux là encore qui amène de
l'inquiétude
je pense là aussi à ces quatre blessés
graves au 30 blessés au total et des
C250 personnes concernées par ce drame
de d'Enghien et
ce qui nous importe plus que jamais
cette la sécurité ferroviaire
je pense que excusez-moi de
m'éloigner quelque peu du cœur du texte
qu'il s'agisse du routier du ferroviaire
des modes de transport en général
il nous faut en responsabilité
replacer au-delà des enjeux des grands
infrastructures des financements parfois
inatteignables repenser ce que nous
devons à nos concitoyens ce que nous
devons leur apporter en garantie et la
garantie du service public du
ferroviaire c'est avant tout la sécurité
cette avant tout cette sérénité dans le
transport nous confions et nous confie
des vies et nous avons le devoir de
mettre tout en œuvre tout mobiliser pour
que nous puissions donner confiance
le réseau ferroviaire français est
classé dans le classement européen 5ème
ou 7e selon les critères retenus les 27
réseaux ferroviaires c'est donc un
réseau qui est fiable c'est donc un
système ferroviaire qui est de qualité
17000 trains chaque jour pour autant
trop
d'accidents et un accident est un
accident de trop d'incident
perturbation et manque de régularité
même nos concitoyens à douter de
l'efficacité des secteur à son
organisation même je souhaite que cette
réforme soit avant tout au delà un
certain nombre de divergences elles
peuvent être exprimées avant tout une
chance que nous puissions donner au
secteur ferroviaire
nous savons que le secteur ferroviaire
français ne peut pas continuer ainsi
qu'il doit sur lui-même en lui-même et
par l'impulsion que nous devons donner
par cette réforme ce s'engager dans une
modernisation absolue et dans des modes
de fonctionnement qui doivent être
rationalisés optimisés pour répondre aux
attentes
des Français je faisais référence à
l'accident de d'Enghien j'ai souhaité un
rapport dans les toutes prochaines
semaines la part des présidents rapports
et Pepi je souhaite qu'ils émettent les
premières orientations pour une
meilleure prise en compte des impératifs
de sécurité
je pense que cela doit passer aussi par
du redéploiement de moyens humains et de
moyens financiers et budgétaire
je souhaite que ce soit fait en
collaboration avec les parlementaires
et donc je saisirai président mais aussi
les présidents de commission sur
rapporteur pour que les deux chambres
soient associées au rapport qui me
seront présentés par le président
SNCF mobilité et de SNCF réseau je
souhaite également que un groupe
d'experts indépendance ou la houlette de
l'établissement public de sécurité
ferroviaire et en lien avec vous
permettent d'expertiser cette
proposition c'est recommandations il n'y
a pas de fatalité il n'y a pas de place
à la tolérance sur quelques risques
ferroviaires que ce soit c'est une
exigence c'est la vôtre
et elle est légitime c'est la mienne et
elle est de ma responsabilité et je
souhaite la réaffirmer à cet instant
solennellement devant vous
les services sont travaillés je disais
qu'il fallait que cette réforme prenne
corps rapidement et l'urgence déclarait
a fait que dans un temps optimisé le
Parlement à travailler de façon
extrêmement efficace cela au lieu de
monsieur le rapporteur qui a su
vulgariser un texte lui apporter des
améliorations sensibles et avec
l'esprit
le travail parlementaire d'échange avec
le gouvernement que je crois pouvoir
qualifier
l'échange de confiance et
de respect mutuel mais surtout de
responsabilité partagée
les services
sont engagés dans la rédaction des
décrets d'applications de la loi un
travail de concertation et de
négociation du volet social notamment de
la réforme va également se poursuivre ce
sont des travaux préparatoires qui sont
ceux à l'élaboration du décret ça sauf
que le par exemple et sa rédaction
amènera à associer l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux de la branche
ferroviaire vous avez très justement
évoqué les conditions dans lesquelles
une ouverture à la concurrence
passée c'était dans le domaine fret a eu
pour effet faute d'avoir préparé le
secteur public
a eu pour effet de déstabiliser
totalement l'acteur historique nous
souhaitons éviter pareil bévue et nous
souhaitons au contraire faire en sorte
que si concurrence doit intervenir nous
n'en sommes pas ni les précurseurs ni
avant de démarches laudatives sur
celle-ci mais si elle doit intervenir
elle interviendra
encore faut-il que ce soit avec des
règles qui soit des règles communes à
chacun des acteurs du ferroviaire et que
l'on ne puisse pas laisser peser sur le
secteur public des règles qui seraient
des règles discriminantes en parallèle
RFM et SNCF vente avec les salariés
engager la réorganisation des
établissements publics
nécessaires pour constituer le groupe
public ferroviaire autour de ces trois
épiques SNCF SNCF réseau SNCF mobilité
enfin ce rapporteur vous avez eu raison
de souligner l'enjeu européen
nous sommes dans le cadre de négociation
sur le volet politique du quatrième
paquet ferroviaire nous avons eu des
échanges et les étaient riches ici nous
avons par la preuve à portée
démonstration à ceux qui depuis
maintenant de nombreux mois apportent la
critique jusqu'à faire émerger le doute
chez certains observateurs de leur
recompatibilité de notre réforme nous
avons la démonstration par la preuve
disait-je que cette réforme de la
gouvernance de notre système ferroviaire
permet de bâtir d'ouvrir une voie
nouvelle à l'Europe bâtir un système
ferroviaire intégré tout en garantissant
aux entreprises ferroviaires à un accès
transparent équitable non
discriminatoire au réseau et c'est avec
beaucoup de satisfaction que j'ai pu
lire dans un quotidien économique
récemment les propos du commissaire
simcalas considérant que notre réforme
ces n'étaient pas ceux exprimés par le
commissaire il y a quelques mois ou
quelques années mais exprimant désormais
combien
la
réforme qui est la vôtre qui est la
nôtre allez dans le bon sens je le cite
était eurocompatible je le dis parce que
même
brandissant les courriers du commissaire
européen même en soulignant les avancées
de la négociation européenne parce que
la France a été extrêmement active même
en soulignant combien nous avions fait
bouger les lignes avec des partenaires
notamment les Allemands un certain
nombre d'entre vous ont souhaité rester
fidèles à une vision passée sans
intégrer ou se réjouir tout simplement
des réussites du gouvernement d'avoir
donné une orientation nouvelle à
l'Europe du ferroviaire modestement mais
avec beaucoup de perspectives pour ceux
qui nous regardent dans des enjeux
d'évolution du ferroviaire européen et
bien la démonstration est faite et
permet de lever tout ambiguïté ou tout
propos de nature à
inquiéter ou à remettre en cause la
compatibilité de cette réforme voilà
c'est moi qui arrive seront important
pour le Parlement pour vous madame
messieurs les sénatrices de sénateurs
puisque désormais par le vote que vous
exprimerez vous serez en charge du
pilotage du secteur ferroviaire vous
serez en charge de cette réforme que
vous devez porter avec le gouvernement
avec les acteurs du ferroviaire les
régions mais auquel vous serez non
seulement associé et pour lequel vous
permettrez l'élaboration de contrat
entre l'État le groupe public
ferroviaire et vous aurez en contrôler
le contenu je conclurai pour vous
exprimer ma gratitude mais remerciements
remerciements parce que la réforme que
nous faisons aujourd'hui
est une réforme ferroviaire qui a été
discutée elle a même été
particulièrement porté
peut-être même vulgarisé au-delà de nos
espérances par un mouvement que nous
avons eu à regretter
tant les arguments ne ne paraissaient
pas être ceux de la réforme et les buts
poursuivis par ceci mais aujourd'hui
nous construisons par cette réforme
un avenir au ferroviaire nous souhaitons
pouvoir compter sur tous sur le
cheminots sur l'ensemble des acteurs du
ferroviaire nous souhaitons pouvoir
aussi redonner confiance aux Français
dans les secteurs ferroviaires et nous
souhaitons ouvrir un nouveau chapitre de
l'histoire de ce secteur qui est une
responsabilité importante pour
l'industrie qui est une industrie
pionnière première au niveau
international et dont nous pouvons avoir
fierté un mot monsieur le rapporteur
votre modestie en souffrira certainement
pour vous remercier vivement c'est un
texte je le sais auquel vous étiez
attachés vous vous êtes engagé de longue
date pour le faire aboutir j'ai pu
compter sur votre volonté votre ténacité
sur votre engagement sur votre passion
même pour pouvoir faire comprendre
toucher du doigt peut-être mettre en
exergue ce que représentait comme enjeux
ce texte et puis c'est un beau signe
c'est un beau signal c'est peut-être
aussi une forme de consécration d'action
publique que de terminer par un texte
qui vous était si important et pour
lequel je le disais vous n'avez pas
ménagé niveau peine ni votre temps
depuis 1998 vous êtes dans cette
fonction de législateur et pour votre
implication je crois pouvoir dire que
vous donnez les lettres de noblesse à
cette mission vous l'avez fait avec ce
texte peut-être est-ce ce soir de votre
dernier séance
dernière peut-être
sauf si le gouvernement prolonge encore
la session ne m'appartient pas
prononcée je n'ai pas cette compétence
je ne voudrais pas créer un trouble ce
soir mais merci cher michel Teston merci
pour cet accompagnement sur ce texte
nommé ministre il y a plus de deux ans
c'était un défi que d'engager cette
réforme j'ai pu compter sur Gilles
Savary
qui est afin connaisseur j'ai pu compter
sur vous et c'est de la qualité des
échanges avec l'ensemble des services
que je pense nous avons donné un signal
fort celui de la réforme celui du
progrès et celui de la volonté une
volonté partagée une nation qui veut
avoir et rendre confiance en son système
ferroviaire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale commune la
parole est à madame Anne-Marie Escoffier
pour le groupe RDS
la dernière ce soir
Madame la Présidente Monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
collègue il est peu de texte de loi à
l'impact aussi important que celui que
nous allons voter ce soir qui aura été
travaillé par les deux assemblées
modifiées enrichi dans des délais aussi
contraints je veux y voir là un double
voire triple effet celui de la qualité
de nos rapporteurs tant ici qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale et je salue tout
spécialement la façon dont Michel
testons a fait science
en ne négligeant aucun contact aucune
audition et en cherchant toujours à
trouver la solution la plus harmonieuse
chère Michel je tenais ce soir à vous
rendre cet hommage bien mérité comme l'a
fait monsieur le ministre je ne voudrais
pas pour autant passer sous silence ou
minorer le talent la diplomatie du
ministre lui-même et de ses équipes qui
n'ont ménagé eux non plus ni leur temps
ni leur volonté de parvenir à un
consensus
tous les débats auxquels j'ai eu la
possibilité de participer ont eu cette
qualité rare d'un vrai dialogue
constructif avec pour objectif de part
et d'autre de préparer la famille SNCF à
une révolution
révolution culturelle sociale et
économique pour préparer un avenir digne
de nos ambitions
tandis que tous craignaient des
mouvements d'humeur de la part des
salariés des mouvements d'inquiétude
chacun a mis du sien pour opérer les
changements de comportement ouvert au
dialogue le résultat est là ce soir la
CMP n'a pas eu à trancher sur des
problèmes de statut de personnel tant
qu'ils avaient été travaillés en amont
les points qui auraient pu être de
désaccord hormis les statues ont trouvé
dans notre volonté commune de régler au
mieux le retour à un groupe public
unifié les voies d'une intégration
aboutie de la structure vous l'avez
souligné et vous l'avez redit
aujourd'hui Monsieur le Ministre l'État
se retrouve désormais pleinement dans
son rôle sa mission de guide stratégique
de garant des politiques globales de la
mobilité les pics de tête prend la lui
aussi toute sa place dans la gouvernance
des deux entités qui lui sont attachées
je m'appelais à souligner ici
l'enrichissement du projet sur
différents points le rôle et la
composition du Haut Comité du système de
transport ferroviaire qui intègre les
associations de protection de
l'environnement agréé ainsi que les
parlementaires de députés de sénateurs
montrant cela la volonté d'une ouverture
à des acteurs incontournable du dialogue
la désignation d'un président délégué du
directeur de la SNCF celle d'un député
d'un sénateur au conseil de surveillance
la possibilité donnée à la SNCF de
recourir au contrat de conception
réalisation
améliorant ainsi de façon certaine
l'efficacité des dispositifs qui
jusqu'ici ne pouvaient pas toujours être
coordonnée les voyageurs et les
parlementaires ont été souvent pris à
témoins dans des réalisations de travaux
d'équipements qui manquait pour le moins
d'une coordination élémentaire monsieur
le ministre ce soir où nous n'avions pas
forcément le sourire permettez-moi de
vous proposer un petit déplacement dans
ma petite garde Capdenac-Gare dont je
sais que vous avez gardé le nom en tête
et qui est le contre-exemple de ce que
nous voulons tous et que veulent nos
amis cheminots eux-mêmes
dans les enrichissements du texte je
veux encore souligner il y a celui
relatif à la transparence de la
stabilisation de la dette désormais tous
les ans SNCF réseau doit rendre public
le montant de la dette qui a été
requalifié en date publique le rapport
du gouvernement relatif à la trajectoire
de cette dette doit quand elle lui
examiner les conditions de reprise par
l'état de tout ou partie de la dette
formons ensemble le vœu que ce
dispositif de par la vigilance qu'il
implique permettra un retour à une
véritable maîtrise de l'équilibre
budgétaire de la SNCF enfin il convient
de relever les mesures prises pour
clarifier le rôle des collectivités
locales notamment des régions dans le
cadre des compétences qui leur ont été
transférées c'est le contrôle par les
régions des comptes des TER et pour se
faire de l'accès à toutes les pièces
justificatives nécessaires c'est encore
l'extension du rôle de de fil des
régions à l'aménagement des gares à la
possibilité de reprendre la propriété
des matériels roulants qu'elles ont
financés au total sans revenir sur tous
les amendements acceptés ici et acté en
CMP je voudrais dire la satisfaction
presque unanime quasiment une année des
membres de mon groupe à l'égard de ce
projet de loi de réforme ferroviaire son
avis favorable sera aussi le même
s'agissant de la proposition de loi
organique de nomination des dirigeants
de la SNCF
je suis pour ma part particulièrement
confiante en la capacité de toutes les
parties prenantes de continuer à
conduire à bonne fin le dialogue social
a poursuivre la préparation de la
concurrence dans le cadre du quatrième
paquet de s'attacher à construire ce
nouveau paysage que nous appelons tous
de nos vœux il en va de la vitalité de
cette belle entreprise qu'elle a SNCF il
en va de l'excellence de ces agents de
la famille SNCF du service public
ferroviaire
merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
commune la parole est à Monsieur André
gatelin pour le groupe écologiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je vous prie tout
d'abord d'excuser mon collègue Rolanda
tech chef de fil du groupe écologiste
sur cette loi retenue aujourd'hui par
d'autres obligations le groupe
écologiste a voté en faveur de ce projet
de loi considérant qu'une rénovation du
système ferrolier français était
aujourd'hui nécessaire le contenu du
texte initial a été assez
substantiellement modifiée lors de son
passage dans les deux chambres du
Parlement et nous nous en félicitons car
les apports adoptés l'ont
indiscutablement améliorer les
écologistes ont défendu des positions
ambitieuses et bien entendu sur certains
points nous considérons que la loi issue
de la CMP ne va pas encore assez loin
sur la dette historique notamment certes
le texte prévoit désormais plusieurs
dispositions visant à préserver la SNCF
de tout en développement qui dégraderait
trop significativement sa situation
financière via l'adoption une règle d'or
en matière de financement des projets
d'infrastructures c'est une très bonne
nouvelle mais nous savons que la dette
qui croit de plus d'un milliard d'euros
par an doit être requalifiée en dette
d'État et porter comme tel sans
continuer à plomber les comptes du
système férié
or sur ce point le texte ne va pas
jusqu'au bout de l'objectif puisqu'il
prévoit uniquement que rapport du
gouvernement sous deux ans examine les
conditions de reprise de tout ou partie
de cette dette par l'État la valeur
contraignante de cette dispositions
interrogent et de surcroît nous trouvons
que le délai de deux ans et nous l'avons
déjà dit et bien long pour une situation
connue depuis la séparation de SNCF et
RFF en 1997
par ailleurs plusieurs groupes
politiques à l'Assemblée comme au Sénat
souhaitait voir introduire une loi
d'orientation quinquennale sur la
mobilité la proposition très proche
d'une programmation plus réelle de la
mobilité des battus et soumise au
Parlement a également été repoussé de
peu nous le regrettons car cela entrait
dans une logique de renforcement de
l'État stratège tout en permettant de
donner davantage de cohérence aux
politiques de mobilité en de manière à
ce qu'elle réponde aux enjeux sociaux
environnementaux et économiques une des
dispositions de la loi portant en
revanche de la cohérence aux politiques
de mobilité par la création d'un schéma
national des transports véritable outil
de pilotage stratégique de la politique
des transports qui permettra d'entrer
dans l'air moderne de la mobilité
la
thermodalité entre le train et le vélo
notamment été amélioré là aussi grâce à
l'adoption d'amendements écologistes le
rôle de l'État a été globalement
réaffirmé mais les écologistes se sont
aussi mobilisés pour que la place des
régions soient renforcée car elle
procure les deux tiers du financement
public du système ferroviaire et assure
des responsabilités croissantes en
matière de mobilité nous nous félicitons
de l'introduction d'une part régionale
de versement transport interstitiel nous
avons bien noté le désaccord du
Gouvernement sur ce point mais une
majorité de parlementaires conscient des
immenses besoins de financement en
matière de transport a souhaité que
cette mesure fiscale voit le jour dans
l'intérêt des habitants et de la qualité
des services publics de transport
la composition de la direction
collégiale des trois instances
constituant le nouveau groupe a fait
l'objet d'important débats et les
avancées obtenus par les écologistes en
la matière sont au cœur de nos
engagements en matière de la
modernisation des instances de
gouvernance de tous les services publics
auxquels nous appelons si nous n'avons
pas obtenu que les régions soient
davantage représentées dans la direction
de la SNCF nous nous réjouissons en
revanche d'avoir obtenu que la parité
entre les femmes et les hommes soient
appliqués immédiatement dans les
instances dirigeantes du nouveau groupe
c'est désormais classique de l'action
des écologistes au Sénat depuis
l'introduction de la parité tension de
haute lutte au sein du Haut Conseil au
finances publiques et ensuite dans de
nombreuses autres instances dirigeantes
de l'État cette introduction
systématique de la parité au moins dans
les organes publics décisionnaires et
quelque chose de pour nous tout à fait
essentiel nous avons également obtenu
dans le cadre de cette loi que les
associations de protection de
l'environnement deviennent membres du
conseil d'administration de SNCF réseau
de SNCF mobilité et du Haut Conseil du
système ferroviaire la prise en compte
des enjeux environnementaux est
nécessaire à la bonne gouvernance de la
SNCF c'est quelque chose qui était
inscrit déjà dans le Grenelle de
l'environnement mais qu'il fallait
complètement entérine par ailleurs la
repérezation des usagers a été acquise
par voie d'amendement écologiste à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est là pour nous
une avancée sociétale majeure qui fait
par ailleurs écho à ce que nous avons
déjà imposé là aussi à l'automne dernier
au Sénat et ensuite à l'Assemblée
nationale par la représentation des
associations consommateurs au sein des
conseils d'administration des sociétés
nationales de production de l'audios
visuel public si on veut un service
public moderne il va falloir que l'on
cesse le système traditionnel de la
représentation de l'État et d'une
représentation plus ou moins marginale
des syndicats de salariés la société
civile existe nous voulons du dialogue
social nous voulons aussi du dialogue
sociétal et en tous les cas la manière
dont cela se traduit au sein des
instances des nouvelles instances des
entités de la SNCF est une avancée et
vraiment une avancée je crois qui fera
date
enfin le volet social a été renforcé je
ne reviendrai pas sur ce point parce que
c'était largement développé mais c'est
un bon point et c'est quelque chose
effectivement en mesure de rassurer
aujourd'hui les les publics les c'est
les les groupes salariés au sein de la
SNCF et enfin encore ce texte est
pleinement heureux compatible il permet
de nous adapter au cadre européen sans
pour autant affecter les droits sociaux
des agents ni ouvrir la porte à une
concurrence qui serait synonyme de
délitement de la qualité du service
public qui est essentiel dans le
transport ferroviaire et à ce point de
ce point de vue là et pour conclure je
dirais le vrai risque de la concurrence
aujourd'hui c'est celui du transport
routier vis-à-vis du ferroviaire il y a
encore forte affaire pour que le report
modal de la route vers les autres modes
de transport moins polluants deviennent
une réalité ce projet de loi donc loin
de régler naturellement toutes les
difficultés et toute l'univers des
transports va cependant dans le bon sens
pour ce qui concerne le ferroviaire le
groupe écologiste votre a donc
naturellement ce texte je vous remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
commune la parole est à Monsieur Luin
aigre pour le groupe UMP
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur madame la Présidente chers
collègues d'abord tout de suite
félicitations pour notre collègue michel
Teston nous ne partageons pas vos idées
Monsieur testonmer Nous vous
reconnaissons comme un très bon
rapporteur qui a défendu ce texte et le
ministre dit tout à l'heure juste raison
que le rapporteur était avait été
extrêmement efficace je remercie enfin
je remercierai
je dirais également que le ministre
Frédéric Viguier a un don rare de
persuasion parce que il a réussi à faire
évoluer de manière significative la
position de la Commission européenne
tout le monde tout le monde n'a pas ses
capacités là alors le cadre dans lequel
nous intervenons de nouveau ce soir est
un cadre qui pose problème vous le savez
tous et d'ailleurs si vous avez lancé
cette réforme ferroviaire c'est parce
qu'il y a un problème le système
ferroviaire fonctionne de moins en moins
bien vous le savez parlé vous-même
monsieur le ministre donc je ne saurais
insisté sur ce point-là mais que l'on
est un accident
qui démontre que la maintenance ce
n'était pas au niveau colonie un
deuxième accident ensuite
nous interpelle directement et nous
inquiète parce que on a là aussi une
difficulté majeure la SNCF RFR sont des
entreprises de grande qualité avec un
personnel également de grande qualité
mais le résultat c'est que nous avons
des accidents c'est une situation très
très préoccupante d'autant plus que si
on regarde au niveau budgétaire le
déficit ou la dette plutôt des deux
entités représentent la moitié du
déficit budgétaire de la France en 2014
alors quel est le bilan que l'on peut
tirer et bien dès 2005 donc c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui le rapport Rivier avec la
Cour des comptes nous confirme que le
nous confirmer déjà à l'époque que le
réseau ferroviaire était en voie
d'effondrement que la part modale du
frais de ferroviaire s'est érodé d'année
en année l'arrivée des camions de 44
tonnes comme la diminution monsieur le
ministre des crédits accordés à
l'engagement national pour le frais de
ferroviaire ont malheureusement
contribué à ce triste bilan le matériel
des trains d'équilibre du territoire et
obsolètes fatigué on n'a pas de
perspective à long terme là-dessus et il
n'est pas juste côté GV qui commence à
son tour avoir des problèmes d'équilibre
économique à long terme
dans ce paysage qui s'assombrit d'année
à l'année l'action déterminée des
régions et leurs investissements massifs
depuis 2002 ont contribué à la dynamique
du ferroviaire avec à la clé une
nouvelle très positive puisqu'on a eu
une très forte augmentation du nombre de
passagers pour les transports du
quotidien depuis octobre 2010 j'avais
pourtant réclamé à mon gouvernement du
haut de cette tribune un Grenelle du
ferroviaire il m'a fallu plus de Nantes
pour l'obtenir à travers les assises et
quatre ans après enfin nous avons ce
fameux débat ici au Parlement que ce
soit l'Assemblée nationale ou au Sénat
on a un projet de loi portant réforme
ferroviaire alors nous avons eu des
discussions très importantes très larges
dans un climat je dirais tout à fait
responsable et correct mais l'analyse de
ce texte me conduit je le confirme un
triple constat premier constat qui vous
est tout à fait favorable monsieur le
ministre parce que je peux que me
féliciter que les fonctions de
gestionnaire d'infrastructures du réseau
ferré national aujourd'hui répartir
entre RFF SNCF Infra et la DCF soit
unifiée vous répondez ainsi à la
recommandation de la Commission numéro 2
des acides du ferroviaire unanimement
partagée par les parties prenantes du
secteur voilà un point sur lequel on est
tous d'accord il y a une deuxième point
sur lequel on est tous d'accord c'est
l'état stratège et vous avez raison et
on vous soutient là-dessus avoir une
vision
là aussi complète large ça commence bien
et donc qui vise à la cohérence du
système ferroviaire et quelque chose
d'important nous le reconnaissons et
nous le et nous le disons on a également
noté et très positivement que l'État
assurerait également le pilotage de la
filière ferroviaire à ce niveau-là alors
vous le savez monsieur le ministre le
plan de charge de la filière
industrielle est en diminution
dramatique à court terme je tire ce soir
à nouveau le signal d'alarme les
industriels que j'ai encore rencontré
aujourd'hui m'ont demandé de vous
transmettre à nouveau leur profonde
inquiétudes et leur forte attentes
d'attention d'action décisives dans ce
domaine
je vous félicite par ailleurs monsieur
le ministre d'avoir retenu l'amendement
que j'avais présenté précisant que la
filière ferroviaire devait favoriser le
développement de solutions industrielles
exportables cette démarche s'accompagne
d'une mobilisation là aussi positive du
Parlement qui aura à connaître les
dossiers les plus importants du système
ferroviaire mais comme rien n'est
parfait mais a priori s'en vote malgré
les propositions que j'ai pu émettre
lors du débat au sein de la Haute
Assemblée notamment en faveur d'une
grande loi de programmation ferroviaire
vous avez enfin accepter de rétablir la
vie conforme de la RAF et vous avez même
augmenté fort justement ces possibilités
d'intervention notamment en matière de
sanction je me félicite également de la
sagesse du Sénat qui a supprimé
l'existence d'un commissaire du
gouvernement qui aurait pu
éventuellement menacer maintenant soit
peu l'autonomie de l'Autorité de
régulation et enfin je note avec
satisfaction que ce texte devrait
permettre de définir de haut niveau de
performance et de productivité tout en
maîtrisant les dépenses à travers une
règle d'or toutefois
toutefois je regrette que ces objectifs
d'assainissement
financiers ne permettront pas d'éviter
une dette qui est en augmentation
constante vous l'avez dit vous-même
monsieur le ministre de plus de 60
milliards d'euros d'ici 2025
ces éléments positifs étant un T je
maintiens un deuxième constat qui lui
m'interpelle et vous le savez vous
n'avez pas amélioré la situation avec
effectivement ce que j'ai appelé la
Nébuleuse d'organismes qui sont
installés aujourd'hui et qui font que il
est pas aussi simple que ça en dehors
des trois épiques plus de gare et
connexion de s'y retrouver je crois que
nous aurions pu être plus efficace je
l'avais souligné j'avais soulevé ce
problème là nous n'avons pas abouti à
quelque chose de plus simple concernant
de même la gestion des gares qui est
maintenue auprès de SNCF réseau je ne
peux que regretter malgré le débat votre
position de statu quo qui va à
l'encontre je vous le rappelle quand
même il va l'encontre même des
préconisations du rapport de Jacques
oxyde du 22 avril 2013 et de la vie que
j'ai qualifié de
argumenté de l'Autorité de la
concurrence du 4 octobre 2013 vous aviez
là une bonne base pour faire évoluer le
système vous l'avez pas utilisé c'est
dommage je m'interroge également sur la
lisibilité que le projet de loi
apportera en région appelée à devenir
des autorités organisatrices de plein
exercice mais dans un cadre des plus
contraints les régions ne décideront
elles-mêmes que des tarifs occasionnels
du TER alors que les tarifs des abonnés
resteront fixés par l'État et les
régions enfin n'obtiennent pas
satisfaction sur le libre choix de leur
mode de contractualisation alors que là
encore une perche vous était tendue et
de la part des vôtres
malheureusement monsieur le ministre et
ça c'était l'entrée en matière
malheureusement monsieur le ministre il
y a une troisième constat qui lui
s'avère plus négatif
en effet il y a toute une série de
questions deux fois qui ne sont pas
traités malgré ces
discussions ses réflexions et ses heures
de départ et c'était en définitive qui
entraîne mon opposition à ce projet de
loi
le premier point je le rappelle porte
sur les plus de 40 milliards de dettes
actuelles alors que ce grave problème je
le rappelle est connu depuis de longues
années votre proposition se limite à
repousser à plus tard l'assainissement
des cons la simple publication d'un
rapport qui plus est dans un délai de
deux ans mais vraiment pas pour moi à la
hauteur de la gravité de la situation
alors même que l'ensemble des organismes
de contrôle économique au stade tinsey
la Cour des comptes ont confirmé qu'il
aurait été possible dès aujourd'hui de
transférer plus de 10 milliards d'euros
à l'État ça aurait été un premier pas
significatif et j'avoue que je n'ai pas
très bien compris la démonstration tout
à l'heure inverse que vous avez fait ici
du haut de cette tribune pour dire que
c'était pas réalisable je pense que nous
aurions pu absorber sans trop de
difficultés compte lui la situation
actuelle c'est 10 milliards je tiens à
rappeler que la Commission numéro 3 des
Assises du ferroviaire a confirmé
clairement que la seule clé de
désantèlement du secteur était la
résorption du déficit structurel
bref pour moi la maison brûle et on a
tendance à regarder un peu ailleurs cela
nous amène un deuxième point fondamental
qui est l'absence d'ouverture à la
concurrence dans votre réforme déjà en
mon premier amendement sénatorial
monsieur le rapporteur déposé à la haute
assemblée était consacrée à une
ouverture maîtrisée à la concurrence des
services ferroviaires régionaux de
voyageurs au Sénat je le rappelle j'ai
été le seul parlementaire à proposer des
à présent une transcription de
l'ensemble des textes européens
notamment la directive 2012 34 sur la
gouvernance et le règlement 2007
1370 dit OSP pour un anticiper des
échéances que vous-même monsieur le
ministre jugé inévitable
c'est aussi ma famille politique qui a
été la seule à prendre ses
responsabilités en tirant les
conséquences des textes communautaires
nous l'avons fait en 2009 avec la
création de la RAF et de le PSF je crois
profondément que ce mécanisme
d'ouverture à la concurrence s'avérerait
extrêmement bénéfique pour la SNCF et
pour les usagers monsieur le ministre il
ne s'agit pas de battre pavillon d'une
libéralisation à tout va mais bien de
répondre attentes de concitoyens 67% des
usagers pensent que l'ouverture à la
concurrence des TER est une bonne chose
telle est la réalité
vous précisez que les usagers attendent
de la sécurité de la qualité du confort
de la régularité et bien ce sont
exactement les conséquences positives
attendues par l'ouverture et la
concurrence par nos concitoyens cela un
sondage Ipsos de mai dernier depuis 1991
depuis 23 ans on sait que ce secteur
devra s'ouvrir à la concurrence face à
un tel défi que fait-on on recule à
nouveau devant l'obstacle
lors du débat en séance plénière vous
avez souligné le rôle de la France dans
le report des échéances du quatrième
paquet ferroviaire et vous en avez
reparler tout à l'heure mais selon moi
il est dangereux de retarder l'adoption
du volet gouvernance qui retarde à son
tour l'adoption du volet technique dont
a besoin notre industrie cette position
de plus monsieur le ministre et de
nature à isolé la France et le fait
qu'aucun candidat français n'est été
retenu pour la présidence de l'agence
ferroviaire européenne ne peut que nous
interpeller sur tous les bancs
alors au lieu d'aborder franchement
cette question et de passer à
l'offensive nous reculons à nouveau en
effet la commission numéro 1 je vous le
rappelle des acides du ferroviaire
présidés par l'un des vôtres Gilles
Savary avait déclaré en 2011 il y a 4
ans que le principe d'une ouverture à la
concurrence était actée
vous avez dit acté j'ai pas vu moi à
l'image de l'urbain la concurrence
instaurée je le rappelle par Michel
Sapin permettrait pourtant le
développement de l'emploi 1 au sein de
la SNCF d'augmenter deux l'offre pour
les usagers et en faire de réaliser des
économies substantielles de l'ordre de
15 à 20% ce qui est considérable les
plus de 800 millions d'euros annuels
ainsi économisés permettrait soit des
investissements supplémentaires soit de
diminuer la charge financière des
collectivités et donc des contribuables
c'est d'autant plus regrettable que la
SNCF libérait à l'international des
entraves franco-françaises et tout à
fait capable de conquérir sans aucun
dumping social des parts de marché de
promouvoir avec une grande efficacité la
marque France je regrette également
votre décision selon laquelle
l'établissement SNCF soit considéré
comme l'employeur unique des AG ents des
trois épiques qui composent ce groupe
public nous revenons donc à la SNCF de
papa si l'on ajoute l'intangibilité des
statuts ça fera plaisir à notre collègue
le inadaptation ça c'est un peu moins
bon à un monde qui évolue si l'on ajoute
que le décret sort que fera disparaître
le peu de concurrence qui existait on
aboutit chers collègues encore une fois
au syndrome de la ligne Maginot
ces nouvelles mesures
anticoncurrentielles vont niveler vers
le bas la compétitivité des entreprises
ferroviaires et mettre hors la loi ces
entreprises sur le marché du fret les
conditions d'application je le rappelle
du décret 2010 qui a 2004 avait pourtant
été négocié et accepté en définitive
monsieur le ministre votre projet de loi
se limite à une réforme institutionnelle
elle ne touche pas et ne traite donc pas
les problèmes principaux qui grève
l'avenir du rail elle ne s'attaque pas
et c'est pour moi ça le principal à
l'indispensable réforme structurelle
dans ce secteur et notre pays a le plus
urgent besoin cette mini réforme n'est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux elle n'est
pas la loi fondatrice du ferroviaire
tant attendu depuis les conclusions des
Assises en 2000 en conséquence et dans
l'attente de la prise en compte des
vrais enjeux que sont l'assainissement
financier l'ouverture et la concurrence
la transcription des directives
européennes et le respect de la
pluralité des entreprises qui composent
aujourd'hui notre système ferroviaire je
voterai avec le groupe UMP contre ce
projet de loi merci monsieur le sénateur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
commune la parole est à Monsieur Vincent
capo canelas pour le groupe
udi
UC
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
michel Teston mes chers collègues nous
parvenons ce soir au terme de ce projet
de loi l'on parcours que monsieur le
ministre a rappelé tout à l'heure et
leur tardive nous permet sans doute de
prendre le recul nécessaire pour essayer
de juger ensemble de ce texte les
conclusions auxquelles la commission mix
paritaire a abouti prouve comme
d'ailleurs la discussion générale et la
discussion en première lecture au Sénat
que sur des sujets d'intérêt général
comme celui-ci celui de l'avenir du
système ferroviaire nous pouvons parfois
trouver des voies de dialogue entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat michel
Teston l'a rappelé et aussi
entre le Parlement et le gouvernement
dirais-je même ici au Sénat ce dialogue
et ce travail est constructif on le doit
d'abord aux deux rapporteurs du projet
de loi Michel deston et Gilles Savary
dont je veux saluer au terme du parcours
législatif le travail remarquable et
passionné je veux dire que
pour une fois
le gouvernement a été attentif à
l'ensemble des sollicitations de
l'hémicycle et je m'en réjouis parce que
ça a permis de construire ce texte et de
le faire évoluer ensemble je crois que
nous avons pu faire évoluer ce projet de
loi d'abord à l'Assemblée nationale et
ensuite au Sénat pour aboutir à un texte
plus équilibré avec des améliorations
significatives sur plusieurs aspects
la commission mixte paritaire n'a ainsi
pas eu difficulté aboutir à un texte
commun puisque le Sénat a largement
prolongé et approfondi les avancées de
l'Assemblée nationale sur les garanties
de accès équitable au réseau dans le
cadre du groupe ferroviaire intégré
sur le renforcement du rôle du
régulateur c'est le Ministre d'en parler
tout à l'heure avec des mots choisis sur
la liberté tarifaire accordée aux
régions sur la clause prudentielle sur
le rôle des régions ou encore la
transparence des comptes
parmi les apports de la Haute Assemblée
le groupe centriste a pris sa part que
je qualifierai de consistante sans
revenir en détail sur chaque amendement
je veux rappeler certaines des
dispositions inscrites sur notre
initiative la transformation du
vice-président du directoire en
président délégué direct toi nous avons
eu un débat là-dessus monsieur le
ministre
le rôle du Parlement dans la définition
des ratios d'endettement de ssncf réseau
et les précisions sur le montant de la
dette requalifiée en dette publique sans
rumuler le couteau dans la plaie je
dirais du bon usage du scrutin public
mais Monsieur le Ministre me comprend à
demi-mots la suppression du commissaire
du gouvernement au sein de la RAF vous
en avez parlé tout à l'heure le
renforcement du droit de contrôle des
régions sur les comptes TER et
l'ouverture des données relatives au
service conventionnés mais aussi
l'extension du chef de fila des régions
l'aménagement de l'ensemble des gars ou
encore l'étude de la création d'un
quatrième épique dans la perspective du
transfert des gares voyageurs nous avons
vu que sur ce sujet les gars voyageurs
il fallait encore continuer à travailler
tous nos amendements ont été conservés
dans la version finale de la commission
Miss paritaire ce dont nous nous
satisfaisons bien volontiers c'est
suffisamment rare pour le noter et je
crois que le dialogue a eu lieu jusqu'au
bout le débat parlementaire a donc été
utile en permettant d'aboutir au final à
un texte d'ailleurs relativement
différent monsieur le ministre
me permettra de souligner du texte
initial mais je crois que vous avez
laissé la place monsieur le ministre au
débat parlementaire et que c'était une
bonne chose compte tenu de ces éléments
comment première lecture mon groupe
votera le texte
issu de la commission mixparitaire il ne
s'agit pas vous le savez d'un chèque en
blanc mais nous devons apporter je crois
des solutions aux enjeux du système
ferroviaire notamment son allaitement
considérable de plus de 40 milliards
aujourd'hui le système ferroviaire se
trouve en effet un tournant et il doit
se réformer les cheminots comme les
voyageurs attendent aussi des réformes
et nous devons bien sûr penser aux
usagers dans les différentes régions qui
souhaitent plus d'efficacité plus de
modernisation et qui souhaitent qu'on
conçoivent le système ferroviaire de
demain ce texte c'est donc un premier
pas comme je vous l'avais dit lors de la
lecture de notre assemblée cette réforme
n'est sans doute pas celle que nous
aurions faites et sur deux points
principalement elle nous satisfait pas
pleinement malgré les avancées obtenues
sur la dette premièrement si nous avons
réussi collectivement à améliorer le
projet de loi avec l'instauration d'une
clause prudentielle mais en précisant et
en complétant le rapport il faut avouer
que le texte reste assez limité sur ce
point comme l'a montré le rapporteur de
la commission des finances entre
collègues François Patriat cette réforme
ne nous garantit pas que les économies
d'échelle liées à la rationalisation des
structures et les gains de productivité
permettront de réduire la spirale
d'endettement de SNCF réseau il reste
ici du travail à faire et chacun admet
que l'objectif se limite à stabiliser la
dette que celle-ci s'établira
probablement aux alentours de 60 à 70
milliards d'ici 2025 c'est donc un sujet
qu'il faudra continuer à retravailler
demain cela pose la question de la
soustabilité soutenabilité pour le
système ferroviaire tout entier du poids
de la dette il y a donc demain une marge
de progression sur ce point il est en
deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
insister pour dire qu'il nous laisse
forcément insatisfait cette réforme est
muette sur l'ouverture à la concurrence
elle prépare sans le dire ou en évitant
de le dire trop clairement alors que
c'est sans doute le grand sujet que le
système ferroviaire va devoir affronter
d'ici quelques années avec le quatrième
paquet ferroviaire nous regrettons que
le gouvernement n'est pas pris la mesure
de la nécessité de préparer plus en
amont cette ouverture à la concurrence
alors que nous avons l'expérience du
Fred ferroviaire et nous savons les
effets que cela pu
occasionner nous plaignions groupe
centriste pour que ce projet de loi
prépare l'opérateur historique et les
acteurs du système ferroviaire à la
concurrence européenne et internationale
c'est pourquoi nous avions proposé une
expérimentation des délégations
le service public nous n'avons pas été
suivis sur ce point-là aussi il faudra
un jour franchir le pas et peut-être
d'ailleurs seront les régions qui
franchiront le pas d'elle-même le texte
européen existant au final si nous
voulons cette réforme du système
ferroviaire après des modifications nous
avons obtenu c'est en ayant l'esprit que
demain d'autres réformes devront être
entreprises pour compléter celle-ci et
préparer les évolutions futures certes
cette réforme est une réforme
principalement centrée sur les aspects
institutionnels Louis l'a rappelé
à l'instant mais elle nous paraît être
un pas nécessaire pour envisager
l'avenir du système ferroviaire français
je vous remercie
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues une voici
au terme de la discussion sur le projet
de loi portant réforme ferroviaire à mon
tour je vais me féliciter au nom de mon
groupe de Mireille cherche en charge du
texte de la qualité de nos travaux du
travail de notre rapporteur michel
Teston je sais qu'il y tenait que c'est
l'un de ces derniers travaux
des administrats de la Commission de
votre écoute monsieur le ministre ainsi
que la disponibilité de votre cabinet et
de l'administration les débats comme le
travail du Parlement à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat auront permis de
modifier significativement le texte
malgré l'urgence une nouvelle fois
déclarée vous le savez nous avons abordé
ce texte dans un esprit constructif et
ce depuis de nombreux mois nous avons
d'ailleurs déposé ici une proposition de
résolution sur les éléments que nous
souhaitions voir traiter dans ce projet
de loi ferroviaire soyez certains que
notre vœu était de pouvoir apporter nos
voix à l'adoption de ce texte
en effet nous pensons que le système
ferroviaire doit évoluer que les
objectifs affichés par le Gouvernement
en la matière étaient plutôt encouragés
encourageant initialement à ce titre
nous ne pouvions qu'adérer à la
perspective de créer un groupe public
intégré réunissant l'ensemble de la
famille cheminotte d'autant plus qu'elle
était souhaitée par les cheminots
eux-mêmes conscient que les divergences
de stratégies entre RF et la SNCF ont
porté atteinte à l'efficacité du système
ferroviaire
de plus les amendements notamment du
groupe GDR à l'Assemblée ainsi que du
rapporteur au Sénat ont permis de
renforcer utilement ce groupe public et
son intégration sociale pour autant nous
demeurons interrogatifs inquiets sur les
conditions d'activité de ce futur groupe
en effet même si rien dans ce projet de
loi nanticipe l'ouverture à la
concurrence rien non plus dans l'empêche
ou ne l'encadre de fait la structuration
du futur pôle public avec trois épiques
correspond à l'architecture d'un secteur
libéralisé conformément aux injonctions
de la Commission européenne en témoigne
l'accroissement des compétences de la
RAF autorité dont nous considérons que
les compétences enquêtes sur celles des
pouvoirs publics vous le savez nous
sommes pour notre part hostile à cette
démarche de libéralisation en effet le
retour d'expérience contrairement à ce
qui est dit ici où là ne démontre pas sa
pertinence l'ouverture à la concurrence
dans le secteur du frais de ferroviaire
a conduit l'opérateur public à se
recentrer sur les axes rentables et à
contre-pied des enjeux notamment en
termes de transition écologique et
d'aménagement du territoire puisqu'une
telle pratique a eu pour conséquence
d'ajouter des milliers de camions
supplémentaires sur les routes je ne
vois pas où elle progrès pour cette
raison nous demandons depuis plusieurs
années qu'un bilan soit réalisé sur les
conséquences des différents paquets
ferroviaires afin d'en saisir tous les
enseignements malheureusement nous
n'avons pas trouvé d'écho ni de majorité
pour adopter un tel amendement par
ailleurs nous sommes aussi inquiets du
renforcement des compétences des régions
en matière ferroviaires les régions ont
fait beaucoup et consacrer une part
significative de leur budget pour
améliorer les services rendus aux
usagers c'est incontestable cependant
nous craignons que cette régionalisation
qui va jusqu'à la liberté tarifaire
fasse voler en éclat la dimension
nationale du service public ferroviaire
essentiel pour permettre les galaxies de
tous les citoyens au service public est
garantir l'unicité du réseau nous sommes
également soucieux et cela ne figurait
pas dans le projet de loi proposer
initialement de la règle d'or imposée à
SNCF réseau son objectif affiché et
permettre la stabilisation de la dette
du système ferroviaire qui atteint
aujourd'hui 44 milliards d'euros si nous
n'avons pas d'objection a priori à ce
propos nous aurions plutôt souhaité que
l'État à l'image de ce qui a été opéré
en Allemagne s'engage à reprendre la
dette le vrai problème est de trouver
des financements nouveaux pour le
système ferroviaire en effet faute de
ressources nouvelles cette règle de
risque d'être fatale à l'investissement
les besoins en termes de régénération
comme les engagements pris par la
commission mobilité 21 devrait nous
conduire à des engagements financiers
plus forts j'espère que nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir sur ces questions
lors de la prochaine loi de finances par
exemple il faut que l'État maintiennent
son niveau de participation au sein du
pôle public ferroviaire il faut que la
fit voit enfin ses financement abonder
nous savons que la refonte de la taxe
poids lourds n'est pas satisfaisante il
faudra également que nous revenions sur
la question concession autoritaires
véritable ronde pour des entreprises
privées alors même que ces sommes
pourraient servir l'intérêt général je
terminerai cette intervention en ayant
une pensée pour les cheminots dont
l'action fut caricaturée alors qu'ils
ont porté pendant 14 jours de grève une
certaine idée du service public
ferroviaire intégré et public j'espère
qu'ils seront entendus et respectés dans
les négociations à venir notamment
concernant le décret socle qui de notre
point de vue devrait avoir pour base le
règlement
rh077 voilà les arguments n'ont pas
changé notre vote vous l'avez compris
monsieur le ministre sera conforme aux
précédents merci Madame
dans la suite de la discussion générale
commune la parole est à modifier
Jean-Jacques Fillol pour le groupe
socialiste
la présidente monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur cher Michel chers
collègues le projet de loi portant
réforme ferroviaire achève aujourd'hui
son parcours sénatorial sous la conduite
de notre excellent rapporteur michel
Teston la commission du développement
durable des infrastructures de
l'équipement et de l'aménagement du
territoire a contribué à améliorer le
dispositif proposé par le projet de loi
poursuivant ainsi la construction d'un
texte essentiel pour l'avenir du rail
dans notre pays la séparation entre SNCF
et Réseau Ferré de France un traduites
par la loi
de 1997 s'est révélé être une très
mauvaise solution pour traiter des
problèmes malheureusement toujours
présents aujourd'hui et de grave
accident de Brétigny et celui
de de Pau des alentours de Pau démontre
s'il le fallait combien l'entreprise
unifiée est nécessaire plus personne
aujourd'hui n'ose défendre cette
séparation et égard aux difficultés
et à l'accroissement de la dette qui
atteint actuellement 42 milliards il
fallait relever le défi je veux vous
féliciter monsieur le ministre pour
avoir engagé depuis deux ans la réforme
du ferroviaire en maintenant un bon
équilibre avec les options de la
Communauté européenne et une vision
moderne du modèle français développement
pour l'avenir de notre système
ferroviaire en réunifiant RFF et la SNCF
au sein d'un groupe public le projet de
loi propose un modèle intelligent euro
compatible et efficace pour l'avenir le
gouvernement a eu le courage de tirer la
leçon de l'échec de la séparation en
améliorant les moyens du service public
dans ce texte afin qu'il soit apte à
affronter les grandes mutations du
transport d'autant que le rail n'a
peut-être jamais été autant concurrencé
par d'autres modes dont particulièrement
la route
la nouvelle architecture de trois
épiques verticalement intégrées renforce
les moyens du gestionnaire
d'infrastructures tout en permettant une
organisation une gestion plus
rationnelle les moyens d'intervention de
l'Autorité de régulation des activités
ferroviaires la RAF contribuent pour
beaucoup à crédibiliser le projet qui
nous est soumis tant d'un point de vue
juridique qui économique la SNCF
entreprise qui appartient à notre
patrimoine national sera ainsi apte à
faire face aux enjeux de demain et à se
préparer à la concurrence des transports
de voyageurs dans les années
2020-2023 tout viendra mon cher Louis
le Sénat a opposé sa marque à cette
réforme et je m'en réjouis je veux à ce
point de mon intervention exprimer toute
mon amitié à Michel Testot notre
rapporteur j'ai eu le plaisir de
l'accompagner tout au long de ce périple
législatif il a su avec calme et
compétences mobilisées beaucoup
d'énergie et de volonté pour aboutir un
vote positif
très large pour dans notre assemblée
c'est un grand souvenir que nous avons
tous en commun je veux évoquer quelques
points sur lesquels nous avons pu
améliorer le projet de loi notamment le
Haut Comité du système de transport
ferroviaire un stand d'information et de
concertation qui permettra d'associer
pleinement toutes les parties prenantes
aux réflexion sur l'organisation le
fonctionnement et l'évolution du système
ferroviaire comblant ou comblant ainsi
une lacune dans la gouvernance actuelle
du système le Haut Comité constituera un
lieu de débat et une sorte de conseil
économique et social sa composition a
été précisée et nous y avons apporté
quatre parlementaires de sénateurs et de
députés le Haut comité
aura la possibilité de s'auto saisir sur
les domaines relevant de sa compétence
ainsi que de constituer des commissions
thématiques spécialisées je me félicite
aussi de la création du Comité des
opérateurs de réseau
il viendra compléter un dispositif
intelligent par ailleurs les budgets
consacrés par les régions financement de
leurs compétences TER et considérable
aujourd'hui si la totalité du matériel
roulant TER et juridiquement acheté par
la SNCF elle est très largement financée
par la Région il nous a donc paru
légitime de confier aux régions la
propriété du matériel qu'elles ont
subventionné afin que ce transfert de
propriété soit réellement effectif nous
avons donné à ce matériel le caractère
de bien de reprise une propriété pleine
et entière implique en effet une
capacité de cession je me félicite aussi
que nous ayons intégré dans le rapport
sur la dette l'opportunité de créer une
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
ferroviaire qui pourrait porter
sur tout ou partie de la part historique
de RFS et qui pourrait nous l'espérons à
terme bénéficier d'un financement
pérenne
enfin et au regard du poids croissant
des interventions financières des
régions chargées de l'organisation des
services ferroviaires régionaux de
voyageurs nous avons fait le choix de
les doter d'une ressource dédiée dont
elles sont aujourd'hui dépourvues
l'article 5 terre crée un versement
transport au profit des régions sur la
base d'un tour régional plafonné à
0,55%. ce versement transport est
institué hors des périmètres de
transport urbain PTU permettant ainsi à
des entreprises non assujetties de
participer à un dynamique des transports
régionaux